[Music]
join my day joe rogan podcast by night
all day i got some holes in mike what do
you think about klitschko uh joshua this
weekend it's a big fight
boring those guys are boring joshua's
got nice joshua is not boring
he's got great power his technique's
okay he's not great
i think klitschko's got a nice job put
people to sleep joe you this is why the
heavyweight division no one cares about
it right
people to sleep the other way by like
being boring yeah being born yeah yeah
you don't mean by like knocking them
silly no but joshua puts people to sleep
knocks people out which is fun to watch
and i'm into that but
it's not i like i just love technique
like i'm a student so you're like a
lomachenko guy
so yeah thank you for bringing silly low
machamp thank you for bringing him up we
got to talk about this
god forget my career podcast history
people
he might be the best boxer that's ever
lived he might
be so i was worried about that we were
going to fight about this but i think
we're on the same page here so
he's on such another level so his
footwork and movement i just can't
come up with a comparable i mean there's
been some amazing boxers way back to
sugar ray robinson and willie pep and
all those guys
paved the way but i feel like everything
evolves right every combat sport even
art and music evolves to the current
state it's at now which you get the best
of the best right now and you go wow
they've learned from ali and sugary
leonard and roy jones and
bernard hopkins and lomachenko is in my
eyes is the best
the way he moves is insane yeah and he's
super aggressive
he's not like floyd mayweather who is
arguably the best ever
you know multiple time world champion in
multiple divisions
49-0 only been like hit solid
maybe seven eight times once when he got
a little rocked by shane mosley yeah
once and then
my donna cracked him once but it's
that's
like over the course of this spectacular
career but
much more defensive oriented brilliantly
defensive very economical with his
approach
but brutal hands hurts him hurts his
hand breaks his hands a lot not a lot of
power lomachenko is
on you like glue stands right in front
of you and you can't hit him and he's
going left and he's going right and he's
in and he's out and you don't know where
the [ __ ] he is
and he's lighting you up so what is this
here's why vasily lomachenko is now
the number one pound-for-pound fighter
in boxing what's that in forbes
damn technically he can't be because his
record
he doesn't he hasn't really been tested
he's got eight fights no no i'm
i'm with you completely i'm just saying
technically yeah he doesn't have enough
fights
i don't give a [ __ ] to be number one i
know he's the best so let me just say so
here's my history with lulachanga so uh
like
i forget it was like four or five years
ago i thought gary russell jr
was the greatest thing since sliced
bread and i still think he's just
phenomenal
incredibly fat the fastest hands since
roy jones easily
and maybe even faster just and
technically just perfect
i thought he was unbeatable i thought he
was the next thing and he's still a
great great great fighter i love him
he thought lumachenko was like who's
this russian dude i don't even know he's
ukrainian never heard of him and he
tore he took russell apart yeah he's a
highlight reel
look at he stands right in front of
people man he just has
such brilliant movement man i mean he's
like
the perfect example of
like like the new wave like
this yeah this side movement yeah he
does this
he does this it's a hop actually he hops
inside
and he'll throw a body shot off of it
when he gets inside on you but he's
basically standing at your side boom
like right there he did it again well
he's not like a brutal puncher
he'll step in or hop in and you know the
funny thing
so i've been hopping around gyms lately
boxing gyms look at that he did it like
three times and here's how it is here's
how i know
here's always there's here's why i think
that he is the next ali
which is that just in the last year
every boxing gym i've gone to
people have taught lomachenko's moves
like as a standard part of classes
interesting right meaning that he's
changing the game
right it's kind of what you were saying
well you know mike tyson did a lot of
that too by the way
people didn't do it as hard as mike
tyson right
you can actually do some of this stuff
of course he's a phenomenal athlete
lomachenko is and
not everyone can do this but there are
some things here that you can do
that have never been done before yeah
like in particular that little hop step
it's actually i had a coach call it the
i think it's called the lomachenko jump
or something
but you can do that you can walk you can
just step in like that
really quickly but people for some
reason just never did it
well tyson did do it tyson learned it
from custom auto custom motto was
teaching this way back in the [ __ ]
50s
but his his style was mike tyson's style
was so much different
because he was throwing howitzers at you
yeah lomachenko
is not knocking anybody out with one
punch no he's hitting you with
multiple barrage of punches but the
thing about they dropped him with a
liver shot but the think about
like what lomachenko is doing with this
steady barrage
is very similar to what i've always said
about jiu jitsu like if you want to
really learn jujitsu
learn jiu jitsu from a small man because
small men
can't use strength and weight and all
the physical advantages they have to use
perfect technique
so if you deal with guys like eddie
bravo or hoiler gracie
or barrett yoshida like the really
little guys or the guys who have this
stellar technique because they don't
have the physical strength with
lomachenko you see the same thing he's
not a one-punch guy
he doesn't have like some tommy hearns
knockout ability or mike tyson type
power
so he's forced to have this brilliant
movement and
footwork which is complete next level
the footwork i think is the best of all
time
and now he's you know literally
embracing the whole idea of him being in
the matrix
he has matrix shorts on now see i like
the matrix comparison i think of him as
the nightcrawler like you know he's just
teleporting around you he's just a
nightcrawler from actually yeah
he's just showing he just like shows up
suddenly right next to you right he
disappears and shows up right next to
you
and just right there that that little
movement and the anticipation of the
counter
and already being two three steps ahead
of you that last fight against sosa yeah
yeah i saw that
that was even better yeah he even he
improved like he was even better i was
like this is getting crazy like
he's so amazing everyone should watch
him yeah he's
he's on another level man yeah he's on a
complete another level so yeah
there's a guy like him in kickboxing who
giorgio petrosian
you've never seen georgia patrol yeah
he's the best for sure yeah yeah
he's some next level [ __ ] too definitely
yeah i think so
he did lose one fight by knockout a
couple of years ago but yeah badly
brutal knockout puncher you're knocked
out uh van risk mullen too yeah
same year i think well it's one of those
things where a guy like andy rusty has
so much power if he catches a human
being
on the chin yeah not perfect technique
but man
but nasty nasty power yeah i wanted to
talk about jermaine duran to me
oh yeah talk about her i mean because uh
it's funny
[Applause]
[Music]
you